il a pris en quelque sorte les français
entre est parce que les français
écoutent aient été à ce rendez vous
nombreux pour écouter une intervention
sur la commune sur la crise sur les
mesures qui la dote annoncée puis un
conseil de défense et ils ont eu droit
en réalité un discours de campagne voilà
et c'est sans doute la campagne qui va
coûter le plus cher de la vème
république puisque depuis le mois de
juillet quarante deux annonces 25
milliards ça pose problème sur le fond
peut-être des annonces qu'est ce que
vous en pensez conditionner le passé ni
terre à la troisième dose ça vous
convient
oui mais c'est la flambée de l'épidémie
ou non attention on est en train de
tomber dans un régime de contrôle
permanent c'est ce que nous voulions
éviter au sénat qui des mesures de
sécurité peut-être le pass peut être un
outil mais si on le pérennise ça posera
des problèmes
le pass sanitaire ne peut pas en france
être une mesure qui va se pérenniser
puisque le présent la république nous
lundi hier soir nous allons devoir nous
habituer à vivre avec le virus on peut
pas s'habituer en plus à vivre en
permanence avec le pass la réforme des
retraites elle est abandonnée par
emmanuel macron alsace était le discours
de la campagne électorale et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il a
pris les français pour des imbéciles
puisque il a dit ce qu'il allait faire
dans les cinq prochaines années mais c
est autant de points de réforme qui n'a
pas fait durant les cinq dernières
années dont justement la réforme de la
retraite c'est est patent et je pense
que beaucoup de français l'ont vu vous
savez il ya des gens qui parle pour ne
rien dire mmmm macro lui parle pour ne
rien faire la suspension des allocations
chômage pour ceux qui refuseraient de
chercher un emploi c'est une mesure de
droite non c'est une mesure qui est déjà
inscrite dans les textes il suffit de la
faire appliquer voilà il ya une
solidarité nationale vis-à-vis de ce nos
compatriotes qui sont réellement au
chômage mais cette solidarité
c'est-à-dire ces droits là doivent
s'équilibrer avec des devoirs